[Music]
you need to get that phone alabama
barker is ready for superstardom at just
11 years old her debut single our house
is now
and she's already mingling with
Hollywood's elite just days ago she had
dinner with the Kardashians and Jennifer
Lawrence there's something more
comforting about the Kardashians yeah
you heard that right
Jayla and Alabama had dinner with a
Kardashian people are actually comparing
you to Miley and also Kylie Jenner
yeah actually yeah the night had a
dinner with all of them you had dinner
with Kylie
where was she had a power dinner I mean
Kourtney Khloe lived on the same street
as s and Alabama and Landon are very
close with Mason and Penelope uh-huh the
other day I told Alabama that was like a
really cool dinner to be a part of she
went today
Kim Kourtney Kendall Kylie Kim Kris yeah
I said what a dinner what Jennifer
Lawrence but she's amazing
everyone thinks cuz the hunger games
she's like all like tough and crazy she
is such a good attitude she's awesome
what does that power group talk about
over dinner if my mind is blown right
now they just they just eat their dinner
and just have a good time yeah they have
a chef it's amazing did they give you
any advice about getting into the
industry at all no but I did show them
my song and they loved it and they have
this amazing thing I was in their
backyard with Penelope and there's this
swing like you would go on at a fair and
it like it's on this huge tree it's like
a nine-foot tree and it hangs you can go
so high it's crazy it's really fun
so do babysit for them would you ever
babysit
I would but they use very high tech
nannies yeah maybe in a couple years
babe so is this dinner gonna happen
again
it could Kendall actually got these
shoes they were
beautiful they were like this high on
her not a man me it would be like all
over there but it was very high and it
was just the cutest shoes she was just
giving out presents she was just like
here here it was awesome Kendall I know
Kris Oh Kris was just giving out
presents and they're gonna have some
more babies joining that family very
soon which is kind of cool too
[Music]